[Music]
welcome back george floyd's
ex-girlfriend takes the stand to testify
about his demeanor the night he died and
a sudden change in his behavior law and
crime's internet levy is here with her
testimony angenette
angelica shawanda hill was just one of
the people in that suv with george floyd
on the night he died she was also with
him in the last hour or so before police
approached
i just got my phone fixed shawanda hill
was in the suv with maurice hall and
george floyd that fateful night last may
hill said she ran into floyd inside cup
foods he offered to give her a ride
how would you describe mr floyd's
behavior
while inside of the cup foods
happy
normal talking hill said they spoke for
about eight minutes when they got into
the suv
then she noticed a change in floyd who
was her ex-boyfriend hill said floyd
fell asleep before employees from cup
foods approached the suv about the
counterfeit 20 bill when they came there
tried to wake him up they tried to wake
him up try to wake him up over and over
and his friend tried to wake him up and
he
kept he woke up then he'll say something
you know he made a little gesture you
know and
knocked it back off hill can be seen on
body camera video from a couple of the
officers including park police officer
peter chang did you guys think about the
car
cigarettes you got your personal items
this is mine i had in my hand
hill could also see a little bit of what
was happening with police and george
floyd at the squad car
yeah he still won't get in the charge
[Music]
on cross-examination prosecutors
questioned hill about her perception of
floyd's health that day did he complain
or shortness of breath at all
no
did he complain of chest pains at all no
and did he seem startled
when the officer
pulled a gun on him
hill was actually kept at the scene as
you can see by that park police officer
that night and she was actually pretty
shocked once she saw an ambulance
arrived she said later in that video
that the police must have done something
to george floyd eric nelson obviously
wanted her to testify because he
believes her testimony supports his
theory of what happened that night that
george floyd may have been overdosing on
drugs angelica
all right internet thanks brian out to
you with more on shawanda hill here she
had made a striking comment that was
objected to but the jury heard it
anyways so tell us about that comment
and elaborate how that could affect the
jury
yeah so lawyers call it as you can't
unring that bell yes of course judge
cahill is going to say you have to
ignore that it's not on the record but
when miss hill was testifying she said
that yeah george floyd was falling
asleep but earlier on in the story he
said that he had worked long hours now
that was objected to i think properly so
but the jury now heard it they're not
going to unhear it and now that's going
to combat what eric nelson is trying to
argue that it was the drugs that called
him caused him to slow down and fall
asleep they obviously heard that he also
worked long hours so the question
becomes was this witness really worth
getting in that small piece of
information when there was so much the
prosecution was able to use against him
right that's a good question there all
right terry the defense subpoena
shawanda hill we know that do you think
that her testimony was effective
absolutely not angelica i think it was
clear she didn't want to be there she
was impatient and at some point she was
dismissive and i think that she actually
confirmed like brian said issues for
both sides on the one hand she confirmed
yes floyd was sleepy he was incoherent
he was unresponsive but then we saw on
cross-examination by the prosecution
that she also said he was startled when
he saw the gun that he answered commands
and he responded so i don't think that
all in all it was a good witness to call
for the defense and i think she
basically came out even for both sides
all right internet maurice hall was also
in the suv that night do you think he's
going to testify
yeah that's a very good question i think
we're all wondering about maurice hall
you could see him in that body camera
video with shawanda hill he was also in
the vehicle that night there was some
discussion today about
they were going into chambers eric
nelson attorneys for the state and judge
cahill to discuss the availability of a
witness we believe that witness was
maurice hall so far we have not heard
from him but we know that the
prosecution is not offering him any type
of immunity in exchange for his
testimony so we very well may not see
him he's already indicated that he would
invoke his fifth amendment privilege
against self-incrimination
should he be called to testify
okay we'll be watching that coming up on
lawn crime daily when the trial of
[Music]
welcome back the trial of a millionaire
real estate heir accused of murdering
his best friend in california will
resume next month we're talking about
robert durst and his murder trial was
put on pause last march due to the covet
19 pandemic a judge has denied the
defense's motion for a mistrial due to
the quote extreme delay durst is accused
of murdering susan berman at her home
near los angeles prosecutors say durst
killed berman because she was a witness
in the still unsolved disappearance of
his first wife cassie the trial is
scheduled to resume on may 17th jurors
will be called in for questioning and
then a new round of opening statements
will be delivered
back now to the derek chauvin trial
where prosecutors have rested their case
but before they did they called one
final witness an expert in use of force
both the knee across mr floyd's neck and
the prone restraint were unreasonable
excessive and contrary to generally
accepted police practices
when in your opinion did the
unreasonable force begin
when mr floyd was initially put into the
prone restraint position and when the
defendant's knee uh was placed onto his
neck and when did it end
when the defendant's knee was lifted off
of mr floyd and he was taken out of the
prone restraint position you observe do
you observe him continue to
uh kick his back legs
are you talking about as he as he is
brought down to the ground yep initially
so there's one movement that's captured
on i believe officer kings and officer
taos body cameras
that looks to me as if officer lane is
grabbing mr floyd's leg and pulling it
and straightening it and rotating it
that is my interpretation of what is
happening there
so yeah he was definitely controlling
his life
meantime as the derrick chauvin defense
presents its case our chief
investigative correspondent brian ross
spoke with a high-profile defense
attorney who has some words of advice
for their team
this week i'm brian ross investigates
the case for derrick shervin we'll talk
with a top criminal lawyer who has
defended a number of police officers and
never lost a case here's his strategy
for defending derek shovin you know i
hate the second guest lawyers because
these type of cases really have to get
in your dna brian but i was surprised to
see that they never made a comment at
all about the video on opening the
defense attorney asked the doctor the
cardiologist
are you saying that
if mr floyd got into the back of the car
that he would not be dead today
and he said he looked at him and said
yeah
and i scratched my head and i said why
did he ask that question that's the
whole point the prosecution's trying to
make
that's this week on brian ross
investigates on the law and crime trial
network
and for our final discussion here brian
what witness do you think is going to
offer the most for the defense
the defense has to put on a medical
expert to say that it could have been
the drugs it could have been his heart
failures and it wasn't in fact the knee
of derrick shoved on george floyd's neck
that killed him so anything that makes
sense right now
and terry we've seen a number of
witnesses for the defense so far how do
you think that they're doing
well i think nelson is doing the best he
can under these circumstances but i
think the witnesses are basically doing
as much for the defense as they are for
the prosecution i mean when you look at
the expert that he brought in just
talking about force i think the jury is
going to decide that the force was
[Music]